Film Courage: As I said before we began rolling,
we have a lot of screenwriters who watch our
channel.
I’m wondering if you can talk about how
you and your writing partner (Jason Dolan)
ended up getting signed with an agency?
Shawn Christensen, Co-Writer of The Vanishing
of Sidney Hall: So we were bashing each other’s
screenplays.
We were roommates in New York.
We were slumming it in Queens.
We were 23-24-years-old and were critiquing
each other’s script and then we decided
why don’t we just write one together and
we wrote this movie, it was called SIDNEY
HALL (not THE VANISHING OF SIDNEY HALL at
the time).
And we were interested in this idea of how
different we were when were 18 and now we’re
24 and we felt like we had changed a lot.
Not necessarily matured, not necessarily a
better person and we wanted to write something
that reflected that.
So we wrote SYDNEY HALL, we wrote it in I
don’t know, a half a year or so?
And we emailed it back and forth to each other.
And then a friend of mine (Paul Wesley) had
a manager and he gave it to a manager and
she gave it to at that time WME (William Morris
Endeavor).
And WME (an agent over there) read it and
really loved it and signed us.
And that’s really how it was.
So I had an actor friend essentially who had
a manager and really it’s Paul Wesley’s
fault that I am in this industry because he
did that.
He also is good with notes and to help with
giving me notes on some of my other screenplays.
I think for an aspiring screenwriter, unsolicited
scripts is the problem, right?
You know, finding out who to give it to or
anything like that.
I think people in the film industry…the
film industry is completely and wholly based
on relationships and knowing people.
And you don’t have to know the big stars
or the big managers or anything like that,
but I think any aspiring screenwriter if they
know someone who plays bit parts on a show
or something like that and that person has
a manager, an agent, I’d say that’s a
good route to go the way we did it.
Which see if they like your script and maybe
give it to them and get it so, if the screenplay
goes to someone of importance who can pay
you to rewrite it or pay for it to be made
or make it into a movie and you know someone
who knows someone that is friends with them,
they’ll read it if it comes from a friend,
as opposed to if it’s submitted just you
know out of the blue from nowhere.